now that's great thanks martin
is that you gary logged on it is yes
that's okay it's all right it's just
coming out golden so i'll just tweak the
um
you name it it's just got your surname
on it i thought it would
couldn't remember anyone else's same
surname
cheers
it's an improvement it did see a louise
but
it did actually i was louise for mighty
at one point
[Music]
uh
just waiting for the chair to join us um
i'm i'm standing in the chair um
no problem hey and gary's here
damon i am here tim and i'm just taking
the back
you've been under the weather so
councilor enrock will step in for me
okay
okay right well we'll we'll make a start
at
three minutes past nine welcome members
of the clay crosstown board
um i'll take apologies for absence i've
got the colleges from
councillor kenyon sadly his mother's in
hospital
uh i also had originally apologies from
from gary golden i know he's
also been suffering with with his death
all the
virus and um as i've prepped for this it
just seems
that i should just continue so but i'm
glad gary you're here anyway
any other apologies for absence um yes
chair
um apologies received from professor
warren manning and cassie hussein
um check i also just remind members that
this meeting has been
streamed live to youtube um i'm also
going to record the meeting for purposes
of a minute so i'm just going to start
that
recording now this meeting is being
recorded
okay thank you
thank you and just and welcome to peter
dewhurst who's actually standing in for
warren manning this morning welcome to
you is anybody else
new this morning to the meeting
has anybody heard from um chesterfield
college
okay right well um yes i was on the
mute there sorry it's uh david malone
i'm the chief operations officer deputy
principal at chesterfield college um so
i'll be replacing richard malcolm
um who's uh left to take over a ceo role
uh another company unfortunately
um so i'll be replacing on the board
thank you oh well welcome david and uh
glad to have you with us and uh
we can chat maybe later on just to get
you up to speed
um anyway declarations of interest any
members who
are requested to declare any existence
nature of any disposable cuny interests
or other interests
and if you are not aware now but this
becomes apparent
during the meeting then please let us
know okay
uh item three minutes of the last
meeting
has everybody had a chance to look at
those and anybody would like to raise
any
uh queries or corrections
unfortunately i'm not getting any very
many um
pictures of people so i don't know if
damien you can tell me
also if anybody's raised a hand
i've not got a hand raised at the moment
chair
right so um i think this is a true
record and i'm really happy to
approve those minutes if you could all
just raise your hand just to let me see
that
that you accept those minutes
okay right um
item four uh feedback from submission
just first like to say that um
congratulations we managed to get the
submission in in time
and we had have had a um confirmation
that's been received
at this point i'd just like to thank uh
nexus for helping us get through this
process
and i'd like to thank carl apps from the
district and his team
who were right to the deadline to make
sure we got our submission in
um but i would like to set this point
that would be the first part of this
process
a long process and believe in me the
hard work really starts now um we've
made huge progress i think
first meetings i attended back in
february as a new cabinet member
um and we've had lots of discussions uh
despite the fact code
maybe hindered some of our progress um
but i'm really
looking forward to this next stage and
hopefully during this
meeting this morning we'll start to
discuss about the working groups
additional board members
and thank you to all of those who have
already been working on these groups
with us
in terms of trying to build up the plan
behind the scenes
and and uh thank you all for your
support and um hard work so far
so i think carl's going to give us some
feedback from submission so far
all over to you yeah thank you chad
sorry um unfortunately my camera
is um having issues so it's a bit of a
massive lag between um speaking and
moving on
so i'm gonna keep my camera
um okay um
[Music]
try again that was a bit better is that
better now
so sorry as i say i'm having a few i t
issues so apologies for this
um yeah the plan has been submitted
we've had
um some clarification questions asked
monday
i'll drop it into chat and mel if
there's anything that you want to raise
because um
if you could just tell us a bit about
the timetable and then i'll drop a few
lists into the chat if that's okay
yeah morning everybody yeah i'm quite
happy to do that thank you
um yeah so first i'd just like to say
congratulations to you really all really
for getting your tip ready for and
submitted by the deadline i know
how much hard work has gone into it so
far and your collaboration and
commitment
um so yeah it's it's really i can
really appreciate that and uh as
carolyn has just said there's a lot of
hard work to go but it's a
little over so you there is your tip has
been
a receipt has been acknowledged and it's
been triaged to make sure that it
um doesn't exceed the word count we've
got all the bits that we were expecting
to get and that you said you were
submitting and it's past that so it's
now moved on to the assessment stage
and as carl pointed out i have just
asked a few sort of quick
clarification questions they weren't um
anything majors nothing that actually
um of impacts directly on the assessment
it just gives us more information that
would be helpful
um so the uh now it's passed through it
started the assessment the
um assessment is sort of like a um
several um individual assessments are
going on by members of the township
staff but also by all the government
departments and their relevant
arms length bodies so that's happening
now
um once this um the about the further
guidance does describe this as a
two-stage process but actually after our
experience with cohort one
it has become a little bit more
integrated so there's an
assessment of your tip and an assessment
of all the individual projects
um that work is going on and we we sort
of hope that that will be completed by
mid-november
and then there is sort of like a
moderation exercise where
an assessment result is agreed between
the individual assessors
and then we do a benchmarking exercise
where we're just ensuring
our approach to the assessment process
has been
consistent across all of the tips and
then once that's
all been completed then we put forward
recommendations to an internal programme
board
which is made up for senior civil
servants from mhclg but also from those
other government departments that have
been involved in the assessment process
and then from that programme board once
if they
they will scrutinize those
recommendations and they will go forward
to ministers either
as equipped to the programme board or
revised on the basis
of their recommendations and then
basically we're just waiting for
ministers to
give us the go ahead um we anticipate
that head to terms offers
will be made some time in the new year
um the third
and uh frequently asked questions did
suggest there's like a two-month time
frame for this decision-making
but as you will know from cohort one it
has taken us slightly longer
so you will have no doubt seen on the
27th of october that
uh heads of terms of deals offers were
made to seven
towns um but obviously you will know
from your
um local knowledge that actually not all
announcements have been made because
newark was one of the cohort one towns
and
an announcement hasn't been made and
there are other towns so they have been
assessed
and recommendations have gone forward
for ministers we're just on hold waiting
for agreement to announcements
being made um so i think with
any other things that i particularly
wanted to say yeah i think
um in terms of what is it will happen in
terms of your heads of terms offer
i think you're quite likely to receive a
sort of
global funding offer which will be based
upon
the number of your projects obviously it
will be based upon
our assessment of your tip as to whether
it is a tip top tip
sorry it's up to you that um and then
based around the um the individual
projects whether there are conditions
attached to our approval so yours your
your offer will be scaled around that
basis
um so you will have seen from the
announcements the sort of levels of
offers that have been made
to towns so i think you just need to
sort of
be mindful of those amounts and in terms
of how you
you are sort of going to be
prepared for your your heads of terms um
i recognize um that you've put forward
a proposal today to bring forward and
recruit procure some consultants to
undertake your business case appraisal
just to be aware that the town delivery
partnership are putting together
a package of support um for business
case now they won't actually be
completing the business cases for you
but they will be supporting you through
the process
in the same way as they have done with
your your
town investment plan so you will be able
to place reliance on their
support as you go through that process
and they are actually holding a webinar
on the 23rd of november
just look at business cases so i think
it would be good for you to be engaged
in that even if
you know you're not doing them yourself
it is helping you
for how it's been approached from a town
perspective
um oops sorry um i don't think there was
anything else i particularly had to say
but i don't know if anybody's got any
questions
about the process happy to take
questions
excellent i think um thank you emily
that was really really useful and
lee he cannot see he's got his hand up
lee
thanks thanks for that sorry if i missed
it but just for clarity
on the global offer that you mentioned
is it likely then or possible that
the global offer would come back to
identify
certain strands perhaps which the
approval
and therefore ring fenced if you like
that
but for those individual strands or
anything
a global offer will be made and then
it's left to the board to choose
yeah i think what if there are any
projects that we don't consider viable
then obviously we would specifically say
that
within the heads of terms but i think
it's more likely to be that
here's your offer and then you can
determine which projects you intend to
take
forward or scale back or not to take
forward and obviously your business case
development
process may impact on that as well
um but i think what you will notice from
the announcements is ministers will
probably want to name check
some flagship projects so
we you know within that announcement so
i think there may be projects that we
would be
keen keener on you taking forward
and they will probably be that will
probably become clear in the heads of
terms
so if there is a for example a project
that has no conditions attached to it
um i we would anticipate that that would
be one that you would take forward but
there is flexibility for you locally to
make those decisions
thank you any other questions
for melanie well she's well we've got it
unfortunately i've only seen about nine
uh screens so um maybe you have to raise
your hand on the um
the actual um icon if you want to get
our attention melanie just just in terms
of
i mean the amounts looked i mean i don't
know the amounts that everybody put in
but the amounts received and the heads
of terms were in sort of like the
mid-20s
which which presumably is quite good is
that is that was that across the board
was that was that quite a high center or
did with people putting in larger ones
and not getting around here
there was only one blackpool was the
only town that went to a check and
challenge session um
sorry just challenge sessions they're
called for this part sorry getting
confused there
so they were the ones that had had
submitted the largest town fundas
but the world of towns that had
submitted slightly over 25 but as you
can see from
the offers um that have been made so far
there's only one that's over 25
so it's all again dependent upon the
quality of the tip as well as the
individual projects
so it's that to sort of stage process
that will will affect the offer that is
made
well we were very grateful for the the
ex what we got from the consultants that
helped us the nexus with the process so
um to hear that second stage of support
is very well confused indeed and uh
thank you and if you'd like to pass that
back that um
because we are we do recognize some
areas
uh as i have probably shown already
projects before we started and
you know i hope that um chesterfield
started from standing start that's
recognized you know we are absolutely a
town that
deserves to have a good run at this and
uh we know the
the challenge ahead but we've made huge
progress and i expect that
yeah okay thank you that's really
helpful thank you melanie
um i think carl's back with us so
um uh uh update on the accelerator
funding process
please calm uh hello so i'm on my phone
now so
sorry if it's a bit um wobbly at times
and so the accelerator funding as
you're aware from the report um there
was an announcement on 30th of june
uh there was a significant amount of
chunk of funding to bring forward
capital
investment projects part of the building
back stronger type work and so clay
cross has received
a half a million pounds of fund capital
projects that quit delivered in this
financial year
and this is to accelerate um the work to
sort of build up
to the um italian investment plan
submission and then to sort of build on
that going forward
so we had to submit it um through the
6151 officer
so for those of you not connected to a
council that's the
the the head of finance really for the
council to say that
um the the the monies
and it hits the um the um
the rules around the spending really and
so there was a number of projects that
were identified that were
helped to facilitate the the delivery of
the town investment plan
and so the purchaser can stub your
building so that's currently a building
that's owned by darcher county council
and used as part of countryside service
that um that building is quite a key
building really in terms of its location
and um it plays a significant part in
the town investment plan
and it was a temporary solution for
derby county council about 30 years ago
to put the concert service in there
and so they've as a service have grown
and we're and we're ready and willing to
move on to um
additional um space so we're working
with them at this point to purchase that
building from them
and because of the challenges we're
looking to see if we can
procure another building to move them
into because
as as we we all in the same situation
that sort of finances are
quite tight so we want to make sure we
can move them into a
suitable accommodation and it doesn't
put them in the financial strain to do
that
so there's 200 000 pounds associated
with that
there's a demolition of former council
depot
on bridge street that's one of the
projects that's been identified in town
investment plan
and that depot was used previously as
units and probably not appropriate
really and they didn't all have
electricity going to them
as a individual supplier so it went to
one meter and then it was fed out of
there and because it was a deco that was
split up so it wasn't really
a fit for a pro um fit for what it was
being used for and the tenants and
probably were getting by but it wasn't
really you know
to help those businesses grow as opposed
by being in that space
and also it ended up being used more for
storage so it wasn't really
um driving economic growth through that
so that's
um going to be demolished as part of
this
and then that creates a development
platform which we can sort of work
through
the town investment plan uh the former
june school
um is a building unfortunately is
no longer um a building that can be
saved
it's it's obviously a beautiful building
as well as we all know um but there's
significant um issues with with the
structure and it's it's now an unsafe
structure
um there's so there's challenges around
that building so
realistically um it's not going to be
viable to save that building
so we're going to look to demolish that
um
that building unfortunately um
because of um funding time scales and
ecology windows and the like and
we weren't able to conduct the bat
surveys that we needed to
within the window because you have to do
it with the sort of breeding
time so that unfortunately was missed
but so
what's been agreed is that we can put
the the funding that's been
here marked for that into an escrow
account so that means it's ring fence to
demolish
the demolition of that junior school so
we can conduct the bat surveys when the
window opens again in may
and then when that and that's something
that we have to do and then that's a
part of planning and then we'll be able
to um
remove that building and then there's
another
piece which um is actually quite
exciting really um
so it's a public art program so we've
got
um the the vents in clay cross that
you're all aware of and
there's an opportunity to restore um one
of the shafts
and then we're looking to project some
public art
onto that and and then and
get that sort of developed from the
grassroots so from the clay cross
residence
junction arts have been procured through
our council procurement
group for that and we're looking to get
um
artists to work with a local community
to come up with the ideas
um i've also asked to look at whether
it's something that we can
purchase the equipment to do long term
because i think it feeds really well
into our
engagement plan long term that we could
potentially project onto the
events um any sort of consultation
events that we're doing
or we could project the plan as they
progress
and as they work and it could be used as
a great and innovative way really to
say to people yeah public art some
fantastic
garb will also use it to inform people
within within the area
so that's that's the project that we've
identified
um so
currently as you can see we've gone over
half a million but we're going to refine
these costs
and we'll see if these can be engineered
down or if we can secure additional
funding to meet them if they are
able to be value engineered so that's
um the report really so it's just to
make you aware
of the um accelerated funding what we're
doing with that and
the um the board will see future updates
on the progress of the identified
projects
excellent thank you carl um yeah this is
a really um
welcome 500 million pounds of funding
that came our way
um and and and under the work behind the
scenes to get
this um this bid in um
and just show that we're actually
working with our partners we can we can
do this
so so thank you thank you particularly
to dcc for
the for working quickly with us to get
this over the line
um yeah i'm really inspired by the arts
the
the art project and i think it's a
really good idea carl but if you can
get the equipment to use as part of the
consultation and what's going on i think
it
it will start to show that we're doing
things i think just doing some of the
work in
in town will show residents that you
know we've got a consultation but we are
going to make this happen
so on the whole it's been a very
positive exercise
any questions to carl um regarding the
accelerator fund or any of these
projects
oh okay unless anybody else can see
anybody i can't see anybody with a hand
raise so
uh working groups item six carolyn
andrew kings
um
yes sorry um yeah i just
wondered that this is accelerator
funding so i i imagine that this isn't
a a just one project it is sort of
focused
on four separate projects because the um
the the old council depot is of course
some some distance from the town center
being on bridge street opposite the out
of town
store uh so it's not it's not really
um
[Music]
it's not really what i would call town
center but i
appreciate you know the the junior
school uh the public art program which
is going to center around like
one of the uh the railway line
shafts and of course the the constantly
rebuilding
um but uh presumably
everybody's happy with that we're not
we're not straying outside the
uh the confines or or whatever the
um the conditions are for that
accelerator funding
it was just really to confirm that point
yeah the the letter has been submitted
um to townhub and they've come back and
agreed with it and if you remember
going back to the town investment plan
map
for clay cross is wider than just the
town center
so yeah they're they're happy that it
meets the criteria that they set out
yeah okay that's that's that's fine
thanks thanks for that carl
lee here can you see you've got your
hand up yeah
one for carl carl apologies i can't get
the report up on
screen so forgive me if it's in there
but on the
projection on the shafts uh
i understand there's it's going to be
some visual digital art that's projected
on and you mentioned
the potential of keeping the kit
to do different things in future as it
got the capability to
provide messaging for instance you know
so
any sort of theme whether we're doing a
campaign around climate change whether
we're doing
you know that sort of thing real life
real time
kind of interchangeable messaging as
well as visual
digital art yeah the um the
the kit hasn't actually been procured
yet so um junction arts are doing uh
this as we speak
um so it's going to be light projection
onto the shaft so
um i suppose just a case of making sure
you can update it and then projecting it
on
the image onto the the screen so um
we've been quite sort of open to say we
would like to use it for
um yeah stakeholder engagement has been
part of that but there's no reason why
it couldn't be used wider and
i suppose there's a potential that if
it's in a position that if or it could
be potentially moved
then we could relocate it to other
places for other messages but it depends
on
the kit the cost and whether we're able
to do that it may be that it's a short
term
project or it could be that it's
something that we look at too for a long
time because
you're right it could fit in really well
with say charlie park comes forward and
we're doing a campaign around childhood
obesity or something like that and
absolutely it could be
conflict to have that message on it as
well as
the town deal work as well
councillor barker
carl are you away you know the
countryside rangers service
uh with me we another atom i've got that
there's been talk about moving on to arc
right
working with the woodland project that
that's based at balls of it
uh and and i know they've been told to
one i just wonder if you're aware of
that
so we're not doing we're not going off
on on tangents if they can work together
and move
to where our carpet used to be that
would be uh
a win-win i think yeah we've met with
the countryside service
three or four times now and with the
estates department at county council so
um all these sort of conversations have
been had and we're just trying to say
where are you because what they also
want to do is use this an opportunity to
consolidate
their services which actually makes
sense because they have to travel an
hour to pick up a piece of
travel an arrow back so what they want
to do is try and consolidate it all in
this next unit so that's kind of what
we're trying to help facilitate well to
help them make some
benefit for me as well thanks
any more questions
okay well thanks for that and um
if ever knows uh banksy where he is
let's send him to ches
to to play across get a bit more
probabilistic
um that's um item six working groups
um hopefully you've seen um
you've all read the uh report on working
groups
the working groups is is going to become
more and more important now i know that
some
these some of these books been
established for some time um but
but you know the detail we're going to
start now in terms of
developing the business case and the
plans so this is
like so this is where the real work
starts so
um this is our last chance really to
make sure we're happy with the structure
the groups
um with the membership of the groups and
um offering or putting forward people or
organizations that we haven't thought of
who should be on there
um carl have you got any more update on
on the paper that you've presented
in terms of the membership so yes um
the the groups have um got
because we're asked that the last
meeting to bring back the who would be
within
the group so i've tried to um
demonstrate
um organizations rather than people
because i i'm conscious that people can
change in an organization and
they might want to send somebody
different because they're more
appropriate for
particular groups or whatever piece of
work so it's just really
um is the board happy with the suggested
um representation on the groups
and have i missed anybody if there's
anybody that they feel that i've missed
and then please let me know and we'll
make sure that they're included
some of the groups are meeting already
and
and some need to sort of start meeting
again i suppose because some of the work
paused while we
were doing the investment plan and then
the youth board
um we've had a discussion with the
school as well
and the college and and looking to see
how we can sort of progress that and
one of the team is going to look at that
um
[Music]
so that'll be looking sort of january
time because it's quite difficult in a
minute with schools
um through the pandemic um so
uh yeah if there's anybody i've missed
simply um
i've seen there's a couple of things
psychosomes on my phone it's quite
awkward so if there's anything in the
chat i'll i'll capture that afterwards
but if there's anything
so that's all something pop up about shy
park i'll change the name of that group
that's
incorrect and then
peter sweet i think
i'm interested to know if lee hicken can
actually help
um double hats for these in terms of uh
um skills charlie park and the youth
so so maybe you're targeting through the
charlie park activities football or
whatever activities going with young
kids swimming whatever just see if you
can
if you can speak to kids in charlotte
park that will be part of the youth
board but also give a
an input on the leisure facilities
locally
and i also would like to reach out a bit
more to
i've already spoken to you to the
chamber of commerce but the fsb
and other business support organizations
um just for you know active people are
active in the community and the business
community
i know we've got a number of businesses
that we're going to talk
you know we're speaking to every
business in um
clay cross in terms of their you know
far more engagement and we're doing that
as a council anyway
um but finding people who who can
actually input
into the um business side would be quite
useful
anybody else got any other
recommendations or
anything what to say on the actual uh
working groups because like i said this
is
this is really important now we'll our
visible developers as good as the people
on these boards representing
the community
leahey king yeah i'll just respond chair
if i could to your
request earlier about the youth shadow
town board so when we
when we started the
work around the health and well-being
hub
a while ago we did actually establish a
group
of youth and younger people
to help inform that decision i think
just because
of the emergence of the town's fund and
putting that project on ice to align the
two projects together i think that fell
away a bit but we can certainly
uh pick that back up and possibly work
with other members
in the community some that spring
immediately to mind
and turn that into the shadow
town youth board as opposed to
you know just having focus on the
what was then leisure center project
okay that's really good because actually
i think um
particularly kids you know i know
there's been challenges in terms of
covered in reaching out
but if you can somehow get reach kids
and the youth
through uh social media and and i'm sure
the
colleges can help us on that one it
would be really useful
and i think it's you know this this
we're trying to do a bid now for the
future
um it's these kids who hopefully living
there and
what shaping their future so that'd be
really good to redouble our efforts in
terms of um
reaching out to young people and there's
a few messages coming up um
i hope you all seen those yeah thank you
davey malone
um we'll be grateful for your support on
that
thank you any other questions on
um working groups obviously if you've
got any
any ideas or people in mind or
organizations
and then let let carl apps know
and uh we'll we'll reach out to people
i'm sure people along the way as well
okay um
additional board members item number
seven again i
think you've seen the report that's been
presented so
again we've been a quite a tight group
so far um
i know we've lost one of our business
members
obviously difficult times at the moment
and so we do need to
um you know we are looking actually to
increase
um our board structure
carl would like to give us an update on
where you are
yeah um so as as you are aware the
the town investment plan that the idea
was always it was a public and private
partnership
and unfortunately um some of the um
the private um representation isn't as
strong as it could be
and obviously we lost um a member as
chairs mentioned so um it's just around
how can we sort of
rebalance that really um and so
proposing that we
um try and get some additional board
members
who sort of ideally would fit in terms
of their skills and a strategic fit with
what the board is trying to do
and the long-term plans and so the
proposal is that we would
um advertise to the
the businesses within clay cross and the
surrounding areas
because social business in strand areas
are likely to be employing people from
clay cross and probably have a
vested interest in this in the
investment goes into there
and then we would do a sort of sifting
in exercise
if possible or if needed and then there
would be although i've called it an
interview i think it would be more of a
a chat really between the chair vice
chair and another board member just to
sort of
make sure that um you know these people
whoever they may be will bring the right
skills bring passion and understand that
it's a bit more than just attending a
board meeting but also
there's working groups to be involved in
there's um
an opportunity to shape the work that's
being done and it's a requirement of a
certain amount of time
and so it's just making sure that they
sort of understand that
and then um though those people would
then be
um invited to join the board assuming
that the board is happy with
recommendations for the people
so yeah that's that's really kind of
it's quite obvious that we need
um private sector involvement in in the
boards that's kind of always been
from day one what we wanted to achieve
and
we could do with rebalancing the board a
bit more to to have a
a greater amount of private sector
involvement i think
um so it's great they'll say that
carries the chair and coming from the
private sector so that's good that he's
sort of leading on this but if we could
have some more
support i suppose that'll be that'd be
excellent so it's just
i'm happy with that um proposal that
suggestion and and then
israel volunteer who would like to join
the
although this interview panel it's more
of a sort of making sure that
the right fit really
tom hi sorry so i
was just going to say if you need any
help from a grocery perspective and if
we've got any intelligence of the left
that may help us identify some board
members as well
uh from the private sector we're more
than happy to think so
um yeah from that point of view and
happy to help
out work possible on the panel if you
need us
to yeah really helpful sorry
sure but it's just them obviously you go
through this process as well with your
own
private public board so any experience
you can bring would be would be helpful
yeah and and just just to as i said
scandal you or jill
in terms of the um what time we can put
in ourselves in terms of going to our
own databases and
doing some work from the district in
terms of reaching out to businesses that
we know about
i mean i'd like to try and get some kind
of complication out to all businesses
and i know we used to do a business
newsletter which i don't know if that's
happening if that can be resurrected
either in print format or or digitally
again working with the chambers and
enterprise agencies or fsb
um adding the d2n2 i think
it'd be nice to just to get get as much
publicity about this as possible
what we can would do chair if if you if
you wish is we can pull together
a a press release and then do
um a mail merge really and send it out
to
some of the the key sort of the top
businesses within the area in terms of
size
and but then also the local businesses
in clay cross and
and that out to them to sort of say make
them aware of the opportunity to join
the board
and but also putting that some of the
expectations around
that you know there is an investment in
time and and
i'm going to sort of help shape that so
if you're happy with that um
myself and team go away pull that
together and
if we sign off um
for yourself and the chair and vice
chair and then we can get that sent out
if that's
appropriate yeah yeah i think i'm keen
to get as many
people to apply i mean i know that the
there's only a couple of places perhaps
for a board member but i genuinely think
if
we're making contact with businesses
locally through any of our
recommendations or or um i just think
perhaps they could be
also become a focus group so you know
you're right the paper's clear that we
want
someone committed on this board who's
going to put the the work
in um but there's lots of people who who
who
would be the sounding board for any in
the idea so
so if we are going to trouble people to
be part of this i just wonder what we
can make
the additional people that might have
applied who've not been successful on
the board
will become a focus group just to help
yeah and i think i think that's
important because they're obviously
interested to help so if we can use them
to help shape the work as well
but maybe in a less formalized way as
sitting on the board but maybe as a
business group that um supports us
okay um and yes danny gates was already
working with her um
so i know she'll she'll tune her local
businesses um
very well so so she'll because
somebody's gonna tap up in terms of
people will be suitable
so ask any more questions
uh else in the meantime if anybody's got
anybody who they think would be suitable
for the board or
maybe more loosely involved with some
kind of focus group
then please again send to me or carl so
at this point they're not going to move
recommendations 6.1
6.2 and 6.3 on this paper
and a the board notes this content of
the report and delegates drafting the
tender spec
to um to carl and his team um the
vice chair and the chair and that the
board endorses the process
for selecting the suitable qualified
consultants to develop
you know to do that uh chair i think
that's the
next one sorry moving in so sorry
recommendations that yeah but
the recommendations that we that we um
you're happy with the process
of actually finding new members for this
board
everybody happy with that
unfortunately i can only see about still
i see nine uh
oh gary sorry i can see you know and and
yeah and gary first and andrew king then
council dale
hey caroline they're all approving it so
you've got about
six people i would say excellent
they've turned the cameras on
right that's approved thank you
i need a bigger screen um
okay then um item eight press release i
think
i don't know if that's been circulated
if not um
is that able to be put up on the screen
yeah i think it's been in this
supplementary papers i think it was
anything
it's in the supplementary papers but i
can upload it onto the screen chair if
you wish
yes please okay just stay with me
all right let me can you see that okay
just enlarge it
okay can you see that okay yes yeah
i can see that and i mean i've seen it
just wanted to make sure everybody was
happy with it this is your
last chance before it goes to
goes out to print
that's pretty much the full body of the
text there
gary you happy with them you you think
you've santa already haven't you
that's right i have yes yeah and i'm
happy with that so
um if if there's no objections or
there's any
no one spotted any spelling mistakes
then
um i'm hoping to get that approved
okay right and the final item
um
so next step so
if you've all seen the report um
pages 16 to 18.
has everybody have opportunities to read
this report
so this is the next steps in terms of
the clay cross
town deal um
recommendations at the end that we need
to
agree to sign off
i was going to ask carl to give an
update on the next steps i think melanie
actually did um
give us quite a comprehensive overview
and i know that's uh
there's not exact the exact timetable
call anything you want to add to this
report
no it's just um notwithstanding what mel
said then
it's great that townshop is is there to
support us and
but i think if we have that resource to
work
as nexus did alongside the town hub and
it should be quite
um hopefully uh quite a
smoother process and and we should then
fulfill to sort of pull up the business
case
appreciate some of this stuff and the
reason we're trying to do this now
and um before we've agreed to heads of
terms is that
um we don't want to go into a
procurement process once that header
terms has been agreed because
that that window then obviously shrinks
at the time we can
work on the business case and we have
kept some money aside
and knowing that we would need to um
pick or somebody to do the business case
element so that the money's there so
that's
that is the bonus and we can make sure
that um
the they're appointed as the heads of
terms sort of come into play so we can
get them
lined up ready and then um on the
proviso that we
you know we get our investment plan um
so i mean i i personally think it's it's
you know we it was critical to have the
um the consultants at that at the stage
i know we did get some
directly from um the actual department
in terms of putting this bid in i think
we've
had 140 000 pounds budget i think fifty
nine issues expense i think am i right
it's about seventy nine thousand left
yeah seventy nine something something
along those lines yeah
okay and um and so this will be a very
different kind of spec to the last one
because this is actually the business
planning this is the
presumably architecture and um
what else are you looking at carl what
what we expected to what kind of
companies are we expecting to actually
put tender out to well we're moving this
now from
the ideas face to work that up from a
good idea into a business case
so um how do we sort of actually do that
and
so understand where the funding undress
has come from so
um yeah that's kind of the next phase
where he's is turning into
something that we can then submit to um
mel and her team and
whoever else and they can they can
understand how the nuts and bolts will
be working
and can actually be delivered so this is
what the next phase is talking about is
that moving from a good idea to
delivery phase i suppose i know we happy
that we've got some
a list of um potential people to
approach or
the there's a this where does this get
circulated in terms of
the right people um it will do it for
our normal um procurement
portal tenders so and there's source
derivative for instance and
and we can alert
secretly qualified consultants on on
this just to make them aware of the
opportunity
um but as at the minute i mean we had 25
people
um 25 businesses and
try and procure us for the the town
investment plan so we've advanced
missions
and then i've had about five or six
freedom of information requests
in the last couple of months around town
investment plan and how can they be
involved
so i think there's quite a lot of
interest out there in terms of
being involved in town investment plans
um town deals obviously
are well populated and well publicized
sorry and there's a lot of consultants
out there who know about them
so we can we we can get it out into the
network to say you know there's an
opportunity here
and make them aware of it certainly well
i'm not that starting to hear that we've
got people talking to business already i
was going to say i mean
you mentioned you mentioned the the
derbyshire but is that just
do we get a lot of um national exposure
to that website or
is it isn't a town's deal hug online
that can actually
cast on it a bit further well that that
and sourced up should they just get
picked up nationally
um so it it goes it does go nationally
so um i mean we had people applying from
when we then procured nexus we had
businesses from london
um we had some of the real national
consultancies
um international ones are playing so the
message does get out there and it is
widely
circulated so don't just think because
it's so starchy it means only doubts
your businesses and we're missing out on
opportunities wider
while the consultancies are we'll pick
that up excellent i've never still had a
hand up
jill yeah sorry i was i was just sort of
gonna um what the thing we we
are trying to do now is move
concepts into something much more
deliverable
and it's to prove to government we are
we're ready to go with this we're doing
it from
uh standing start in some in some ways
but we've moved a long way in quite a
short time
and that we are committed to what we're
doing so by
starting to procure people before we've
got the heads of terms in
is a real what we're trying to show is
this board is really behind it really
wants to move things forward
um and i wouldn't worry about getting
somebody
in to do this work we're going to need
several different types of consultants
to do this work because the projects are
quite wide spanning
um and i think we'll have people
queueing up to do them
because they're actually really quite
interesting pieces of work
for consultants that's all i've got to
say on that no no i think that sums up
very nicely
and and i agree and i'm i'm certainly
keen to uh
to get going now because um you know
like i say i i
recognize looking at some of the other
bits that got in that some some areas
have
clearly had these all ready to go as it
was so we you know we
this this should preclude us you know
this is we are
exactly the type of talent should be
supported um but i
you know would be good to now try and
see more the detail
i know melanie actually mentioned that
we'll get some ongoing support so i just
wondered if melanie you've got anything
to add to that before we start
putting specs out that we're not
duplicating something that you might be
delivering as well
um no i don't think because the sorry
um can you hear me
no the the town delivery partnership
they won't be actually be able to
produce their business cases for you
it's a bit like they couldn't produce
your ticket for you
but they can advise you and to put you
through the process
and then help you sort of guide it
from a tax fund perspective we will be
issuing some additional guidance around
um our expectations around business
cases
um um for the town's fund so there will
be working to that guidance and
to be able to support you so it's sort
of like an add-on
um so i say much in the same way as
they've been working with
your town investment plan so i think
you'll find it really helpful because i
do think they've been very
helpful with you to deliver you know
putting together your town investment
plan so i think you will find it will be
a similarly helpful
and some helpful support um but it may
be different maybe i mean jade
who is no it's not jenny is your um town
delivery partner
coordinator isn't she jenny adams yeah
that's right
that's right yeah yeah um so it probably
you don't whether jenny will be
coordinating or whether it will but
whether there will be other people
involved but obviously it's people with
different specialities who will be
supporting you through the process so
you might
might start meeting new people but
they're all geared up to uh
to be providing it thank you for that
update melon that's reassuring
uh lee hickenfc got your hand up uh yeah
just
just to jump in i'm picking up on a uh
point that
joel was making there in some of the
elements of the town
the investment plan are further along
than others so the health and well-being
hub
charlie park for instance we've been
working with
a number of uh bodies including sport
england
andy james who's on screen and i
certainly don't want to put him on the
spot
but we just have to be careful that we
knit
the support that we need together with
the support we've already got so
in that in that uh aspect i know we
we're looking to access a range of
uh expertise and specialisms through
sport england or already i don't if andy
you want to
not necessarily confirm that but you
know if you want to add anything at that
point about
things consultancy etc that we're
accessing already
i think the only consultancy you really
need now um
lee is finalizing the sopg
ground plans and then getting a
professional team on board
to actually start to firm up some of the
plans and things
yeah yeah no i i have to say yes i'm
aware the leisure
is working up nicely already i know a
lot of work sort of going into that and
again we
had a lot of conversation with dcc and
the college as well
the other some of the sites um but it's
really going to ramp up now
so so so i have no hesitation in
asking you to support the
recommendations of this report
and that we move to a draft tender spec
um and it looks like um the director
of um an edcc for the developments the
chair and vice chair
uh to help with this process and
that the board endorses the process of
selecting and appointing
suitably qualified consultants to
develop the full business cases and um
and be assured that with looks like
we've got support in terms of finding
the right people to do this
so have i got a second for that proposal
i can't see anybody i'm sorry let's
reach out
you've got councillor park and
councillor and andrew king
are both um seconding right excellent
and uh and um a show of hands for
just to to put that through
which i can't see anybody's hands but um
yeah maybe shout if you don't approve
okay okay you've got about seven eight
those that are showing thinking it's
done then thank you very much
um i think that's the i've got about my
agenda
okay well um that's the
last item on the agenda this morning
thanks so much um i know we've had a
long um process to get to stage one
and um hopefully by the next meeting
we'll be
running away in terms of the deciding on
these consultants for the next stage and
the business planning and getting these
working groups set up
and so thank you for your continued
support and
i look forward to working with you all
to get to the second stage
thank you very much
you